here are some other corporate emails  that mistakenly got sent out recently  kay Jewelers emailed free rush shipping  for our two carat should have worn  protection engagement rings yeah that  was good  Apple Apple email maybe this is the  iPhone that will finally fill the empty  chasm in your soul Starbucks Starbucks  email pumpkin spice lattes are back just  in time for him to leave you oh come on  she has it coming  AARP emails read our newsletter quick  before you die Petco Petco email tell  your out-of-work college grad it's beef  stew  hotels.com emailed we no longer report  bloodstains to the authorities wink wait  do what you want  and finally diapers.com emailed enjoy  special discounts even for butterface  babies  [Applause]  you